well we it's it's a shifting balance
right you know Face Time used to be a
thing where we determine how uh how hard
you worked or how devoted you were to
the company based on you know what time
you showed up and what time you left and
yet stories abound of people you know
who sat at their desks and did nothing
they just needed to have the face time
so that they're bustle that they were
there you know because that was the the
metric of of that company
um so you know you have productive and
unproductive people at work and not at
work
you know whether and so we just have to
shift slightly that um that our ability
not to see them you know we we have to
learn to trust
um which is which is a hard one one of
the things that I find really
interesting is I used to be I've pulled
back on you know I used to be like I
don't want you working on nights and I
don't want you working on weekends I
want people to have their time because
when we had a traditional nine to five
sort of mentality I wanted people to let
go of work and have personal time I've
actually pulled back from saying those
things because now I don't know when
people want to work maybe they want to
wake up late or you know go to the gym
in the morning and start working at 10
or 11 but then they'll work to seven or
eight because they're happy to do that
and so now I think uh we have to learn
to allow people to figure out their own
schedules now the missing pieces is
communication what must happen for any
employee who wants to have an uh a a
schedule that is different or
alternative to what the company's
expectations are or what the standard is
is they have to communicate
communication is different than making a
demand or just sort of making an
announcement but rather like hey you
know I'm happy to work uh later
um I really want to have my mornings to
get my kids ready and go to school
um uh would it be okay if I started work
at 11 or 10 which means I just wouldn't
I wouldn't be on any meetings can we
push meetings past 10 o'clock and it's a
discussion because the answer is yeah
probably you know we almost all
situations there's a very very
comfortable uh agreement that everybody
can be comfortable with I think what
both employees and employers get struck
by is is the demand in the announcement
like you will do this and that goes both
ways I think we just want to be heard
and seen as I said before and
um but communication has to happen there
has to be communication because like I
said I think I like I I think a lot of
them
employees feel
embarrassed to ask or afraid to ask but
if you have good leadership and and
somebody who cares about creating a a
positive working environment they should
be open to pretty much everything